the man who plowed into two bicyclists
killing them on a busy road this past
November learned his fate today 27 year
old Marco Benitez was under the
influence when he was driving on East
Flamingo near Maryland Parkway 8 news
now reporter Victoria Saha was in the
courtroom as emotions ran high
Marco Benitez will be serving a minimum
of 6 years in prison
a morning as Benitez was just inches
away from the family of the victims they
didn't hesitate when it came time to
tell the judge why they think he needs
to stay behind bars as you see the
factors agreed to see if it gets he
deserves the absolute Max on these
countries on the evening of November 4th
of last year Benitez was driving
recklessly when he plowed into
36-year-old Antonio zambala and his
longtime girlfriend 37 year old Karina
Lopez who were on their bikes the two
had recently moved to Las Vegas the
horrific moment captured on a dash cam
video was shown in court
benitez's truck was shown hitting a car
stopping briefly and then hitting the
bicyclists he then drove off the
opportunity to stop was ignored more
than three times getting away was his
choice anymore
zabala's sister didn't want any leniency
toward Benitez honestly even the maximum
amount of years he will get will never
compare to the life sentencing he's left
me and my family with zabala had a
teenage son a family friend spoke on
behalf of him she didn't just take away
my father he took
him though Benitez will be locked up for
16 years he could spend up to 40 years
in prison I think now is when we start
our healing
um
it's gonna be forever with us there's a
huge hole
in addition to the two cyclists killed
in total 10 Vehicles were struck and six
of the people suffered minor to moderate
moderate injuries